[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert lehmann für den sport
und das sind den nachrichten themen von
heute
diskussion um entlastungen die ampel
koalition will mit einem dritten paket
rentnern familien und studierenden
helfen die länder fordern einen
nachfolger für das neurotiker
italien vor der wahl giorgia meloni will
als chefin der rechtspartei fratelli
d'italia neue ministerpräsidentin werden
und baut selbst weil die lieferzeiten
für wohnmobile lang sind und viele teile
fehlen greifen immer mehr camper zum
werkzeug der
[Musik]
europäische gaspreis stieg heute auf ein
neues rekordhoch die angst ist groß dass
russland bei gar kein gas mehr liefert
seit beginn des ukraine kriegs versucht
die bundesregierung die steigenden
kosten mit immer neuen ideen aufzufangen
es ist nicht ganz leicht den überblick
zu behalten deswegen zeigt bluten
leinhos jetzt erst mal das was schon auf
den weg gebracht wurde und danach
schauen wir auf das was noch dazu kommen
soll die zwei bisherigen
entlastungspaket summieren sich laut
bundesregierung auf rund 30 milliarden
euro dickster brocken die 300 euro
energiepreis pauschale für erwerbstätige
die steuerpflichtig sind sie wird im
september ausgezahlt studenten und
rentner bekommen sie nicht ebenfalls ein
großer posten die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage die allen stromverbrauchern
zu gute kam dazu steuerliche
entlastungen erhöhungen beim
arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag beim
grundfreibetrag sowie der
pendlerpauschale ab dem 21 kilometer der
dreimonatige tank rabatt für benzin und
diesel sowie das neun euro ticket laufen
ende august aus ein einmaliger bonus von
100 euro pro kind wurde im juli
ausgezahlt für einkommensschwache
haushalte gab es weitere einmalzahlungen
200 euro zuschuss zur grundsicherung und
270 euro heizkostenzuschuss wenn sie
wohngeld beziehen
jetzt also soll das dritte paket kommen
und zwar schnell und zielgenauer und
gerechter so soll auch für rentner und
studierende was dabei sein die bislang
leer ausgingen allerdings liegt die
koalition in den details noch weit
auseinander ines trams
der spd-parteichef beim
niedersächsischen wahlkampfauftakt in
cuxhaven er stellt sich den fragen der
bürger groß sind ihre sorgen angesichts
explodierender energiepreise unter
hochdruck so klingbeil arbeite die
regierung an einem dritten
entlastungspaket das niemanden
zurücklassen schon bald soll es kommen
ich erwarte dass jetzt in den nächsten
tagen wirklich auch konkret wird wie wir
die bürgerinnen und bürger entlasten
einige punkte sind ja genannt wir wollen
das wohngeld ausweiten das bürgergeld
das auf den weg gebracht wird wir wollen
mieter schützen aber es geht insgesamt
auch noch darum weitere entlastungen zum
beispiel die frage der einmalzahlung zu
klären neue zahlen des statistischen
bundesamtes fast 11 prozent der bürger
werden von ihren wohnkosten erdrückt
bald dürfte es gar mehr überlastete
haushalte geben vorwurf der größten
oppositionspartei an kanzler scholz den
worten folgten zu wenig taten
ankündigungen sind gut allein wir
kriegen seit wochen seit monaten
ankündigungen schon vor der sommerpause
dass es bald entlastung geben würde sie
müssen endlich entschieden war werden
die menschen warten bringen drauf noch
liegt das dritte entlastungspaket nicht
auf dem tisch auch aufgrund des
konflikts innerhalb der koalition die
fdp nimmt das tempo raus
wir werden das sehr gründlich machen wir
werden das gemeinsam machen wichtig ist
dass wir dabei betrachten dass auch
diese vorschläge auch finanziert sein
müssen die rückkehr zur schuldenbremse
ist für uns außerordentlich wichtig dass
permanent die fdp bestimmt in welche
richtung es geht das ist und bleibt
inakzeptabel es muss so sein dass der
soziale zusammenhalt in unserem land
gewährleistet bleibt klar scheint die
bewältigung der sozialen
herausforderungen wird zur zerreißprobe
für die ampel koalition
noch bis mittwoch gilt als neun euro
ticket dass viele fans hat die wünschen
sich eine verlängerung oder zumindest
etwas ähnliches während die
verkehrsminister der länder heute in
einer sonderkonferenz überlegten was da
möglich sein könnte precht berlin schon
vor bürgermeisterin giffey will eine
verlängerung lösung des ende des jahres
kein match hat mir
das neun euro ticket hat die
fahrgastzahlen nach oben getrieben
steigende energiekosten belasten zwar
zusätzlich doch die verkehrsminister
basteln an einer nachfolgelösung das hat
hoffnung bei den fahrgästen geweckt ich
find's toll wenn der nahverkehr einfach
erschwinglicher wäre weil ich glaube für
das kostet eine fahrt fast drei euro ich
glaube für sechs euro hin und zurück
wird ich dann tatsächlich das auto
nehmen und das finde ich schade
ich würde mir wünschen dass der
öffentliche nahverkehr umsonst wird aber
halt dann muss wirklich vorher ausgebaut
werden den bundesländern fehlen bereits
jetzt milliardenbeträge für den
öffentlichen nahverkehr
sie sehen den bundesverkehrsminister in
der pflicht die milliarden löcher zu
stopfen und die verkehrswende zu
finanzieren das neuen euro ticket das
sehr gut angenommen worden viele
wünschen sich eben auch eine nachfolge
hier ist der bund gefragt wir erwarten
dass der bund hier auch
finanzierungsvorschläge macht das ist
bisher noch nicht erfolgt doch der
bundesverkehrsminister spielt den ball
zurück und nannte die ergebnisse der
heutigen konferenz enttäuschend und
meiner erfahrung ist die wehr erst über
geld redet der wird die reformen nie
erreichen aber es geht hier nicht nur um
finanzielle fragen sondern es geht vor
allen dingen um strukturelle fragen und
die müssen jetzt am anfang stehen ich
bin etwas erstaunt dass das immer wieder
verweigert wird das bundesland berlin
will das 9 euro ticket ab oktober bis
zum ende des jahres fortführen zur not
auch im alleingang es soll ab dem jahr
2023 vom bundesweite eine lösung geben
aber wir arbeiten hier für 2022 eine
lösung die dann auch gegebenenfalls ab
oktober gelten kann so soll der
bundesregierung mehr zeit eingeräumt
werden für 2023 eine folge lösung
anzubieten
wirtschaftsminister habeck will an der
umstrittenen gas umlage festhalten sie
aber noch kurzfristig ändern es sollen
weniger firmen von den geldern
profitieren die die endverbraucher ab
oktober zahlen müssen der grünen
politiker sagte in berlin es sei mehr
als unbefriedigend das unternehmen von
der umlage profitieren könnten die
eigentlich gute gewinne machten
möglicherweise sei eine änderung aber
gar nicht mehr möglich wenn die umlage
ab dem ersten oktober erhoben werden
soll er die energie krise trifft auch
großbritannien im gegensatz zu den
deutschen wissen die briten seit heute
wie viel mehr sie in den nächsten
monaten zahlen müssen auf der insel wird
ein durchschnittlicher preis für gas und
strom festgelegt und zwar alle drei
monate neu ab oktober gilt die
energiekosten steigen um 80 prozent eine
familie zahlt dann umgerechnet 4200 euro
pro jahr bisher waren es
2330 michael haselrieder berichtet
helen hayes pflegt ihren vater zu hause
in ipswich im osten englands der 86
jährige hat alzheimer braucht rund um
die uhr betreuung
ihm wird die ganze zeit kalt deshalb
werden wir die heizung nicht abstellen
können sie ist tag und nacht an und auch
die stromkosten sind enorm gestiegen
ich glaube niemand kann sich vorstellen
was das für die schwächsten familien
bedeutet
im herbst werden die energiekosten
weiter steigen und das obwohl
großbritannien schon vor dem krieg gegen
die ukraine kein russisches gas
importiert hat das problem der gaspreis
in europa hat sich seitdem verdreifacht
auf ein neues rekordhoch
sie sind sehr abhängig vom europäischen
gasmarkt früher hat europa als ganzes 40
prozent seines gases aus russland
bekommen heute ist weniger gas auf dem
markt deshalb steigen die preise die
auch wir zahlen müssen
johnson will keine entlastungen mehr für
die bürger auf den weg bringen sondern
dass der nachfolgeregierung überlassen
doch die suche nach einem neuen premier
dauert noch an in der größten energie
krise seit jahrzehnten ist
großbritannien führungslos eigentlich
müsste die regierung jetzt
entscheidungen treffen denn
hunderttausende briten wissen nicht wie
sie ihre strom und gas rechnungen noch
zahlen sollen auch helen hayes macht
sich sorgen wie hoch die preise noch
steigen und wie sie ihren vater und ihre
familie durch den winter bringen soll
schauen wir in die ukraine zum russisch
besetzten atomkraftwerks abriss ja das
konnte gestern nur noch über eine
notleitung mit strom versorgt werden
heute ist von den ukrainischen
betreibern zu hören dass ein gestoppter
reaktorblock wieder hochgefahren werden
konnte das akw war zuletzt mehrfach
unter beschuss russland und die ukraine
geben sich dafür gegenseitig die schuld
friedensverhandlungen mit russland das
fordert eine gruppe von spd-abgeordneten
und politikern und dringt auf eine
diplomatische offensive als vermittler
schlagen die parteilinken china vor
grüne und union reagierten entsetzt
widerspruch gibt es auch vom spd
außenpolitiker roth er sagt wer den
frieden wolle der müsse die ukraine
jetzt politisch und militärisch so
unterstützen dass russland an den
verhandlungstisch gezwungen werde
wichtige nachricht für alle die früher
in rente gehen und sich etwas
hinzuverdienen wollen
bundesarbeitsminister heil will die
bisher geltenden einkommensgrenzen
streichen das geht aus einem
gesetzentwurf des arbeitsministeriums
hat vor zurzeit können arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer erst nach erreichen der
regulären altersgrenze unbeschränkt
nebenher arbeiten
in die usa dort hatte eine razzia in der
villa von ex-präsident scham vor fast
drei wochen aufsehen ausgelöst zum
ersten mal würde das privatanwesen eines
ehemaligen präsidenten durchsucht in
diesem fall drums villa in palm beach
dort beschlagnahmten beamte des fbi mehr
als 700 dokumente die teilweise als
streng geheim eingestuft wurden jump
wird vorgeworfen gegen das spionage
gesetz verstoßen zu haben und gerade
eben wusste das
justizministerium die grundlage für den
durchsuchungsbefehl veröffentlichen mrt
wissen was steht da drin
also in dieser grundlage ich halte sie
mal hoch ist sehr sehr viel gescherzt
aber aus dem was offen zu sehen und zu
lesen ist erklärt sich jetzt warum es
eben zu der durchsuchung gekommen ist im
februar hatte trump tatsächlich schon 15
kartons an die behörden übergeben in
denen sie dann auch geheime dokumente
und zwar 187 geheime dokumente gefunden
haben auch aus der kategorie streng
geheim
darunter sogar informationen über das
nationale verteidigungssystem der usa
stichwort atombomben und auch über
quellen aus geheimdienst bereichen das
sind die am besten geschützten
informationen auf dieser basis hatte man
große sorge dass dann noch mehr ist im
juni hat der präsident an weitere
kartons herausgerückt auch in diesen hat
man geheiminformationen gefunden und das
beweist im grunde genommen dass es die
absicht gab diese zu behalten und die
razzia fand daneben statt und hat
tatsächlich weitere besonders geheime
dokumente zu tage gefördert also die
ermittler gehen davon aus es war absicht
diese dokumente zurückzuhalten und ganz
offenbar waren sie vermischt mit allem
möglichen mit zeitungsausschnitten mit
persönlichen notizen immer sie durch
gelesen hat oder wem immer trump sie
zeigte der saat top secret informationen
und das spielt eine große rolle weil
wenn es zu einer anklage käme dann
stünde auf die weitergabe solcher
informationen auch eine größere
haftstrafe dankeschön für diese
information live aus washington mrt
wissen war das
vor einem monat zerbrach in italien die
regierung draghi ende september gibt es
neuwahlen große chancen auf den wahlsieg
hat ein rechtes bündnis
angeführt wird es von der rechtsextremen
partei fratelli d'italia
deren chefin giorgia meloni will
ministerpräsidentin werden kritiker
werfen der 45 jährigen vor sie seien
migranten feindlich und
europaskeptisch sie selbst sagt sie
werde die demokratie verteidigen
mehr von annette hilsenbeck
offiziell beginnt der wahlkampf heute
doch in den sozialen medien tobt der
schon posten die spitzenpolitiker
täglich sie gibt sich siegesgewiss und
laut aktuellen umfragen hätte die
rechtsextreme giorgia meloni gute
chancen ministerpräsidentin zu werden
diese nation braucht eine regierung der
tat der freien menschen eine regierung
die nicht gekauft werden kann ich sage
euch ehrlich ich denke ich kann eine
solche regierung für
ihre position stark nationalistisch ihre
themen traditionelle familie christentum
eine harte anti migrationspolitik und
widerstand gegen einfluss aus brüssel
auch wenn sie nun im wahlkampf erklärt
sich an eu haushaltsregeln zu halten
clooneys party d'italia gilt das post
faschistisch und war immer in der
opposition ein plus in der wählergunst
umfragen sehen sie mit über 24 prozent
ganz vorne mit ihrem rechts bündnis zu
dem auch berlusconis forza italia und
matteo salvini schläger gehören könnte
sie die wahl gewinnen der stärkste
konkurrent ist die sozialdemokratische
partito demokratie co sie liegt in
umfragen knapp hinter melanies
rechtsextremer fratelli d'italia
man muss sich entweder für das eine oder
das andere lage entscheiden und es gibt
die demokratische partei die linke mitte
und unsere loyalität zu den werten der
verfassung und zu europa ein großes
bündnis jenseits vom mitte rechts block
zu bilden bislang jedoch die geplante
einheit sehr vielen kleinen parteien die
wahlen könnten zu einem starken
rechtsruck in italien führen
so oder so ähnlich sieht wohl der traum
vieler aus die mit caravan wohnmobil
oder wenn in die urlaubs freiheit
aufbrechen 14 millionen sind es
hierzulande zwei mehr als noch vor zwei
jahren ein boom der schnell ins geld
gehen kann denn auch hier steigen die
preise mancher wird auch deswegen jetzt
zum heimwerker ein trend des caravan
salons in düsseldorf
lothar becker
hunderte wohnmobile stehen hier auf dem
parkplatz der messe düsseldorf die
besuchenden des caravan salons können
hier eine ganze woche lang kämpfen
manche machen hier sogar richtig urlaub
nur die wenigsten planen hier ein neues
wohnmobil anzuschaffen wobei das
natürlich auch
vor acht jahren zwar 340.000 gegeben
jetzt wollen sie 355 schuss gleiche auto
egal welche art caravan oder wohnmobil
die preise hoch die lieferzeiten lang
inzwischen durchschnittlich neun bis
zwölf monate für rund 107000 euro gibt
es dieses modell mit einer innovation
für mehr platz bei gleichem raum der
alkoven wird erst am ziel aufgestellt
genauer gesagt auf gepumpt das spart
etwas sprit bei der fahrt und schafft
ordentlich platz am urlaubsort es geht
aber auch deutlich günstiger einfacher
und individueller einen gebrauchten bus
oder transporter selbst ausbauen das ist
sogar mit relativ wenig do it yourself
erfahrung machbar ist das ganze auto
kostet 12.000 euro also inklusive
basisfahrzeug gesamte ausbau wir haben
von photovoltaik auf dem dach batterie
kühlbox heizung ist alles drin sind
module möbel also man muss noch nicht
mal wirklich handwerklich so erschien
sein und wir haben jetzt drei wochen um
auch das auszubauen also das ist total
erreichbar das ist ganz sicher der
einzige kaminofen auf dem caravan salon
in düsseldorf in einem komplett selbst
ausgebauten wohnmobil das kann
theoretisch aus jedem fahrzeug entstehen
ein alter krankenwagen ein hubdach drauf
und der winter steht vor der tür ein
wundervolles projekt um dem nächsten
jahr dann kämpfen zu geben
autor wetter gibt es in weiten teilen
deutschlands gerade nicht gewitter mit
starkregen lösen das hochsommerwetter
erstmal ab im tiergarten in nürnberg
wurden außengehege überflutet im norden
brandenburgs
musste die feuerwehr überschwemmte
gärten abpumpen dort stand das wasser
teilweise 50 cm hoch bei pinneberg in
schleswig-holstein kämpften die menschen
mit überfluteten straßen und in sachsen
linien heftige hagelschauer runter und
das bleibt wohl auch erstmal so jetzt
zum sport norbert nach der auslosung der
champions league gestern gab heute die
anderen europapokal ja und dass dann der
erst der fc köln überhaupt heute in den
lostopf gelangt war das hat er einen
echten kraft leistung gestern abend in
ungarn zu verdanken drei zu null stand
ist am ende für köln nach dem tor von
kingsley schindler gegenwehr war der fc
hatte sich damit nach der 1 2
hinspielniederlage doch noch für die
konferenz nicht qualifiziert die 3000
mitgereisten fans aus dem haus
und heute wurden in köln folgende
gruppengegner zugelost partizan belgrad
upc nizza und der erste fc slowakei aus
tschechien und eine klasse höher in der
europa league da spielt union berlin
gegen sporting braga malmö ff und us-
der sc freiburg trifft auf und blieb
lakos piräus karabach agdam aus
aserbaidschan und auf den fc nord für
beide deutschen vereine durchaus lösbare
aufgaben
start der biathlon sommer wm in
ruhpolding mit dem 7,5 km super sprint
bei den frauen da wurde die
italienerinnen dorothea wierer
weltmeisterin und bei den männern holte
ein deutscher den titel philipp horn die
faust als zeichen des triumphs bei
philips der neue super sprint
weltmeister kann sein glück noch gar
nicht fassen ich habe es läuft noch
nicht so richtig realisiert dass man das
jetzt weltmeister titel nennt aber es
war auf jeden fall ein grandioses rennen
es ist unglaublich schön wieder vor
zuschauern zu laufen vor allem vor
heimpublikum beim letzten schießen spürt
horn auf bahn fünf förmlich unter der
zuschauer sechs athleten fehlerfrei
gehen gemeinsam auf die schlussrunde im
zielsprint grün sich horn zum
weltmeister im super sprint silber und
bronze ging an die schwedin samuelsson
und feeling
der deutsche automobilkonzern audi
steigt ab der saison 2006 und 20 in die
formel 1 ein und zwar mit einem fahrzeug
das heftig mit biosprit und
elektroenergie angetrieben wird künftig
müssen alle rennwagen diese
nachhaltigkeitsforschung der film ein
ehrgeiziges projekt schnelle erfolge hat
audi für eher unwahrscheinlich und
zur deutschlandtour da hat alexander
kristoff die zweite etappe gewonnen der
norweger kam nach rund 200 kilometern
von einigen nach marburg im massensprint
als erster ins ziel bester deutscher max
kante auf rang fünf und gesamtführender
jetzt der italiener alberto region
morgen dann die dritte etappe es geht in
die berge von freiburg ins schöne
schauinsland ja mal sehen mit welchem
wetter denn der deutsche wetterdienst
warnt verbreitet vor schweren gewittern
mit teils extremen starkregen wie sich
das in der nacht und morgen weiter
entwickelt erzählt gleich christa orden
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um 10 im
heute journal
die gesamte heute redaktion wünscht
ihnen ein schönes wochenende
auf wiedersehen ist gut
[Musik]
guten abend heute brodelte es ja richtig
in schwül heißer luft wir hatten heute
morgen hier diese wolken einer kaltfront
die kam aber kaum fahren dafür schossen
land schnell die gewitterwolken ihnen
die höhe und das war wie ein
flickenteppich orte mit platzregen
direkt neben orten an denen es trocken
blieb und so geht das auch heute nacht
noch weiter es bekommt nicht jeder etwas
ab aber wenn dann kann das starkregen
von 60 litern pro quadratmeter in kurzer
zeit bedeuten denn die gewitter ziehen
aktuell sehr langsam sie sind sehr
ortsfest die größte gefahr gibt es dabei
im osten und im süden des landes im
westen und im nordwesten da bringt der
frische wind aus nordwesten von der
nordsee schon etwas stabilere luft das
ganze bei 13 bis 19 grad heute nacht
morgen brodelt es dann im osten und im
süden teils heftig weiter wieder mit
starkregen und überschwemmungsgefahr aus
nordwesten setzten sich im tagesverlauf
dann arbeit die größeren wolkenlücken
langsam durch dazu gibt es morgen auch
mal einen tag ohne große hitze bei 20
bis 26 grad ist es kühler und angenehmer
als zuletzt diese temperaturen bleiben
bis montag es gibt nur vereinzelte
gewitter am sonntag im nord osten und im
süden aber größtenteils beruhigt sich
das wetter kommen sie jetzt gut durch
diese nacht